les dinosaures comme j'aurais voulu
comme l explique j'ai vu un peu partout
dans les magazines sur internet et à la
télé que les dinosaures avaient disparu
il ya 65 millions d'années
alors là je vous arrête car 65 millions
d'années il s'agit de l'ancien datation
aujourd'hui grâce aux nouvelles
techniques de mesure on parle plutôt de
66 millions et puis dire que les
dinosaures ont disparu
c'est oublier leurs descendants pas de
raison de crier à l'extinction six
oiseaux et dino son proche parent c'est
l'heure de reprendre les découvertes
dans l'ordre chronologique pour
comprendre ce que oiseaux et dinosaures
parfait mais si munich des dinosaures ça
fait longtemps qu'on en trouve difficile
de pointer du doigt la première
trouvaille leur existence il a fallu
qu'on l'approuvent et ça ça n'a pas été
un mince travail c'est un circuit chao
owen qu'on doit l'invention du mot
dinosaure un nom qu'il a donné à des
orgies quand est-ce que venus
d'angleterre que william buckley avait
trouvé il reconnu tout de suite leur
posture érigé comme des oiseaux ce
n'était pas des lézards rampant le terme
dinosaures quant à lui renvoie au fait
que c'était des reptiles oui mais
terriblement grand mais cela va changer
suite à une découverte en allemagne
moins de vingt années après en 1859
on découvre combien natus un reptile
tout petit mais lui aussi avec les
pattes redresser c'était donc bien à
dinosaures mais curieusement miniature
bipèdes et léger il fallu se rendre à
l'évidence tous les dinosaures n'étaient
pas des titans surdimensionné le pompon
pu décrocher quand deux ans plus tard
dans les mêmes gisement été exhumé un
autre site poids plume apparemment
bipèdes
mais pas seulement tout dans son
squelette rappelait le petit dinosaure
comme sonia tus mais la pression de sa
silhouette a révélé un élément capital
en plus si un score de dinosaures il y
avait des ailes faite de plumes
magnifiquement préservé quelques curieux
mélange que de voir des dans une queue
et des plumes ainsi rassemblés pourtant
elle était bien là duvet que rémy pas
moyen de s'y tromper les dinosaures
pouvait être petit et à plumes
et archaeopteryx fut le premier à le
démontrer sans servait-il pour voler ou
planer parade et se réchauffe et montrer
qu'il est le chef ou se cacher peut-être
tout à la fois
après tout les plumes ont toutes ses
utilités alors qui sait ce qu'il ya de
sûr c'est qu'entre dinosaures et oiseaux
il n'y a qu'un pas moins que ça
assurément il suffit de regarder ces
deux oiseaux disparus dont le bec est
ornée de magnifiques dans
le collagène des eaux fossiles et tous
les dîners oiseaux découverts récemment
ne sont venus que raviver une très
ancienne théorie vieille de plus de cent
ans les dinosaures ne sont pas éteints
non car cela fait maintenant un siècle
que l'on sait que les oiseaux sont des
dinosaures survivants il n'est plus
permis aujourd'hui d'en douter